Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to torment DeepMind’s
new AI called Ada with tasks that are
impossible. Kind of. And then, see
if it is smart enough to solve them.
Now, you see, we talked about previous AI
techniques that were able to learn over
time. For instance, NVIDIA’s little
knights were able to learn to fight
by themselves. But this took 10 years
of training. Not 10 years in our lives,
10 years in their lives as they live inside
a simulation, which, with a quick computer,
will only take a few days to simulate.
In a different paper, AI agents started
out like this. And over time, they learned to play
football and some really advanced techniques. And
there was no referee, so they also learned
to be not too kind to each other. Ouch. So,
how long did this take? Well, these folks also
trained for years, in simulation time that is.
And now, with DeepMind’s new AI, this agent
will hopefully be able learn cool new things,
and hopefully it will not take years. Yes,
we are going to build a virtual playhouse,
and play a little game. Throughout the game,
this little window to the world is what
the AI sees. Only we see the whole level.
So now, little AI, you have one job. And
that is, to hold the black cube. But,
there is a problem. What is the problem? Well, of
course, the fact that there is no black cube! Not
one in sight. But we have a secret. The secret
is that if we touch the black pyramid with the
yellow sphere, out comes a black cube. However,
psst, this is a secret. The AI does not know about
this rule and has to find out by itself. And
you know what, let’s make it even worse. If it
touches the yellow sphere to the purple pyramid,
both get destroyed, making this task impossible
to finish. And you know what, let’s make it even
worse. Give it a strict 20 second time limit. So,
good luck with that, little AI! I can’t wait
to see this. This is going to be a lot of fun.
So, let’s see. Round 1. It starts
exploring, likely to find the black cube,
picks up the yellow sphere, dashes
away, and…oh boy! Bad news. Real bad.
It proceeds to touch the purple pyramid,
you know what that means, right? Oh yes,
both of them get destroyed. Little does
the AI know, the task is now impossible.
It still tries to combine some objects
together, maybe something good happens,
but we already know. Nothing good happens
here. And then, the time runs out.
Now comes the interesting part. Did
it learn anything from this? I am so
excited! Let’s start again! Hmm…it says
let’s not do what we did earlier. That’s
a good start. It takes the black pyramid, and,
there we go! Good job! We got the black cube,
and now it is time…for a victory dance! Fantastic.
So, is there any point in running round 3? Oh
yes. Yes there is! The goal is that we wish
to see what it learned from the previous
success. Did it do it just by chance? Does
it really understand what just happened? Let’s
see. Oh boy! It is going straight for the correct
answer. It really knows what just happened.
It truly uncovered the rules of this game,
and now it is busy optimizing its
route to solve it even quicker.
I love it. And when running a similar task for two
of these Ada agents, they learn the rules of the
game independently, but that is expected. However,
what is not expected is…look at that! Wow. They
learned to throw to get this task done quicker,
and later on, they even learned to work together
to be even more efficient. So now, yes, it is time
to hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars, because
what you are seeing here is learning happening
not in years, but in a matter of seconds.
Learning is so quick here, it is happening
right before our eyes. I can’t believe it.
So if we can’t believe this, what do we do? Of
course, we make the task even more difficult. The
previous task could only be solved by lifting
things. So how about creating a level where
lifting things make you lose immediately? That
sounds fun, right? This new level can only be
solved by pushing. Of course, the AI does not know
that, so in round 1, it starts out lifting with
predictable results. This was not a success.
So let’s see what has it learned? Round 2.
Look, it starts pushing instead. And when pushing
the two cubes together, got ‘em! Good job. That
was super quick learning. Once again, the
learning happened right before our eyes.
So, what do we do now? Of course, we make it
even harder. Let’s add a bunch of unnecessary
rules and a ton of objects to distract the
AI from finding the yellow pyramid. Which,
by the way, doesn’t even exist. Yet. See if
it can see through our little tricks. First,
some exploration happens, and transmutation also
happens. A lot of it. Something touches something,
and some other something appears. This doesn’t
even seem to make any sense. Note once again that
only we see these rules and the whole map. The
AI does not know anything about the rules and is
playing this game for the first time, and only
sees this tiny window to the world. And later,
my goodness, look at that! With a stylish move,
it chucks away the yellow box that is in the
way. Fabulous! Then it holds the purple box,
so what happens then? Look at the rules, yes, it
makes the highly coveted yellow pyramid appear.
Great! Then, it goes straight for the goal.
Learning is happening here too…and super quickly!
And in a different cooperative level, each player
has to touch their corresponding sphere to get
their pyramids, and when these new pyramids
touch, we are finished. For the first try,
they try to explore and eventually succeed. But
do they really know how they succeeded? Do they
know which actions were the ones responsible
for their success? Wow. For only the second try,
they absolutely smashed it. That is just about
the quickest and most effective solution that
I can imagine. Holy mother of papers. This
little AI is learning incredibly quickly.
And I have to be honest, when reading the
paper, I was a little worried if it could
learn at all. Why? Well, because it is not
getting any intermediate rewards. What does
that mean? It means that this game is a cruel
teacher that does not tell the AI during the
game how well it is doing. Only when it won
the level does it tell the AI so. Before that,
no information is given to the AI whether it is
doing well or poorly. This is especially difficult
if we need to perform a chain of actions
to win the level, like you see here. And,
my goodness, I am absolutely stunned that the AI
can still do it at all, let alone this quickly.
So, in just one paper, we went from learning in a
matter of years to a matter of seconds. Wow. This
truly feels like seeing history in the making in
artificial intelligence. What a time to be alive!
So, what do you think? What would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!